elles ont été blessée aux bras et aux
jambes par les projectiles dégagée par
la bombe
les deux habitants de saône-et-loire
devait donc aller à un concert à lyon le
soir même et s'apprêtait à aller à la
boulangerie de la rue victor hugo au
moment de l'explosion
le compagnon de l'une d'entre elle
témoigné ce matin là on était là et à
voiles blancs et passe à exploser
une perte de m'accompagner ma
belle-soeur elles se sont fait opérer
parce qu'elles sont plaints de billes
dans les jambes donc
voir retourne pour voir ce qui se passe
et les deux victimes ont été
heureusement légèrement blessé il ya des
blessures par des corps étrangers qui
nécessitent des explorations des lésions
une des patientes actuellement a pu être
vu ce matin par pour un entretien
psychologique
nous avons fait en sorte qu'ils nos
médecins psychiatres puisse être présent
aujourd'hui les deux bourguignonne
pourrait quitter l'hôpital demain ou
lundi
comme elle treize personnes ont été
blessées dans cette explosion pas encore
revendiqué